as the scale of Destruction in there not
becomes clear bodies are still being
found in the mod
drivers derna is the epicenter of the
disaster caused by a powerful storm that
burst two dams nearly a week ago it
swapped multi-story buildings into the
sea with sleeping families inside
but it wasn't just terna people were
also washed away by torrents in Susa
another coastal town the aftermath is
devastating in the towns of albeda
al-maj and several others in eastern
Libya
have killed thousands of people and
displaced more than thirty thousand the
Frantic rescue Force are still on the
way but for those who survived there is
now a risk of another disaster
local officials say decomposing bodies
pose a health risk and can lead to
water-borne diseases
they are now working on a complete or
partial evacuation of the city of dharna
Libby has had two rival governments
since its revolution one in Tripoli in
the East and the other in the West
many people in disaster heat areas
accused the authorities of negligence
believing the collapse of dams could
have been avoided
an official from Tripoli has promised a
comprehensive investigation
the investigation will involve local
authorities and officials of successive
governments for any negligence or
Omission carrying out new inspections
and determining the cause of death of
victims represents critical factors not
only for restoring the rights of those
victims but also establishing the
responsibility for any negligence or
fault
firm and harsh measures will be taken in
this respect
thousands of survivors are pinning their
hopes on foreign aid in politically
divided Libya
people here are desperate to get
medicines surgery supplies food shelter
and body bags for the burial of the
deceased
and libyans hope they will arrive before
it's too late
is a journalist from
make sure to subscribe to our channel to
get the latest news from Al Jazeera